pourquoi la mixité sociale est elle un
pilier de la laïcité
ça c'est la grosse question sociale est
un des piliers laïcité en ce sens que
une société qui sera très inégalitaire
sur le plan social les gens qui seront
opprimés qui sont extrêmement
défavorisés auront tendance à avoir des
à se rattacher à des doctrines dur à
essayer de trouver des doctrines mesures
qui permettent de contester cette
société et ce sera pas forcément des
doctrines religieuses le stalinisme par
exemple a été une idéologie totalisante
de gens qui étaient au prix mais c'était
pas une idéologie religieuse mais c'est
l idéologie contestataires donc si la
laïcité veut pouvoir générer un débat
démocratique et je débat démocratique
respectent certaines règles
elle a tout intérêt effectivement à
avoir ce que la laïcité historique a
appelé la doctrine de la solidarité
c'est à dire reconnaître qu' il n'est
pas normal si vous voulez que certains
soient des privilégiés et puis d'autres
soient défavorisées et qu' il n'y ait
pas un échange qui permettent une
redistribution des directions
[Musique]